it's a very powerful engaging touching
gritty film it's poetic it's funny it's
it's dark it's beautiful it's ugly it's
it's so many things at the same time
it's always fun to be overwhelmed once
you're in the theater so it helps if you
don't know a lot about it and then you
just get sucked into a story that
completely overwhelms you bataan it's
how do you make the audience root for a
character that doesn't seem that kind of
likable at least to start with I have
one simple word for it it's sincerity
because of course the character is not
really likable to some extent but he's
pure there's no bad intention he is what
he is and he speaks what he thinks and
he's very sincere and I think that is an
enormous and beautiful quality working
with Jacque is as an actor is probably
an experience of a lifetime
working with Marion is an experience of
lifetime as well so there's everything
to be excited about but you know it's
it's it all comes down to very simple
things I guess it's it's all about
authenticity pure emotion sincerity and
honesty that's what it is I never
considered things to be career changing
I never look at things in that
perspective but of course I know Jacques
is well respected Mariana is well
respected and I of course you have an
awareness about the fact that the film
is going to have a certain buzz but
that's not why we do it we do it because
we're telling a story that we connect to
on a really profound level and that's
what we're about and after that the fact
that it opens opportunities and it gives
us a chance to work with other amazing
directors is just an enormous bonus
you